Matt Babel Entertainment Tonight Canada
you still got like an apology it's okay
how much fun do you guys have making
this movie a lot more fun than I
probably ever have now is it one of
those experiences that really stands out
I'm sure that happens from time to tell
me you do a film you're like this is one
that this is never happened to me like
what no no no I mean having this working
with this many women and having this
much fun yeah usually you're maybe one
or two of them women on set but you know
but we had eggs I don't know what that
means yeah no it was a not it was not an
easy shoot it was not like the boys
where they were done at five had
cocktails and went to a play or a play
we literally were working 12 to 14 hour
days juggling kids juggling two or three
jobs lying on the floor trying to get
some sleep
finding bits of life somewhere and in
the middle of that mess we managed to
just bond over rolled-up meats and
literally other songs
Rihanna songs which were always sung
poorly by one I would never have the
huevos did like go to you know I mean he
doing right in a room yeah yeah so
here's the thing Danny ocean is dead in
the movie oh don't say you just gave it
away cuz I don't see this one other
things in the trailer I think it might
be in the trailer is there because also
in gravity which came in a long time
we're going to kill them ah
pretty early I just removed George from
anything he's always trying to muscle in
on my romantic comedies so I said dude
next three films I got to get rid of him
are you okay with that he said fine so I
gave him a nice healthy career and then
I began to remove him yeah from every
film that we ever did together make
sense I think it's fair so do i passing
the torch was a little bit hasn't been
any banter between which franchise can
do better because I actually think this
one will outdo previous versions well
they're kind of I mean we went down a
slightly different fork in the road it's
not him it's not a remake isn't even a
sequel yeah it's just kind of taking
some of the pedigree I mean Steven
Soderbergh was on to producers and he
was the one who originally called me and
you know said that Gary had this idea
but they're kind of really different I
think and I think they had the same kind
of sense of humor you know but they're
different world different energy it's
like that it can keep going you know
then we'll pass the torch to somebody
else and they can sort of take you know
their turn and and I think the the style
of film that this is it's timeless I
mean you go all the way back to Frank
Sinatra really yeah you see the car
Association it's really great they did
they did the remake yeah yeah guys
George George to the remake of the real
Ocean's eleven so you copied somebody
yeah George comedy somebody I'm glad
you're here copy these homework I chose
to originate he chose to copy yeah we're
not comparing and then weird copy